okay we have to talk about the rapidly
spreading a meme or demand or talking
point this idea of abolish the police
and this has basically three forms
sometimes it's literally abolished the
police
sometimes it's defund the police and
sometimes it's simply called ACAB all
cops are bastards the some version of
this is essentially what we're talking
about here now I believe that this
catch-all is completely miscalculated I
believe it's inaccurate and I believe it
dramatically helps Donald Trump get
reelected if it were to become a
prominent theme of Democrats and and I
can't believe Joe Biden would do it but
if Joe Biden were to adopt this in the
time remaining between now and the
election I'll tell you why and then we
can talk about it we have a problem with
police brutality in the United States we
have a problem with lack of proper
training for police we have a problem
with militarized police departments in
this country we have a problem with lack
of police accountability in the United
States we are seeing overwhelmingly
peaceful protests demanding that these
issues be dealt with and that's a
beautiful thing they were catalyzed by
the horrific killing of George Floyd in
Minneapolis and protests like this and
rallies like these have not been seen in
the United States for a long time and it
is a great thing but abolish the police
defund the police sometimes the
messaging can seem inspirational or
catchy but it doesn't actually make any
sense and it's not popular and it is a
huge risk if the left is going to adopt
this as part of a platform heading into
November abolish or defund the police is
using a sledgehammer when what you need
is a velvet glove and I'll explain why
and I'll defend my position on this and
then if you disagree I want to hear from
you the problem is just not as simple as
police have too much money and if we
take the money away we solve the problem
the problem is not as simple as police
need to be eliminated and then we would
be much better off including replacing
police altogether with social service
agencies or community
watch groups or whatever the case may be
the problem is sometimes too much police
funding for the wrong things the problem
is sometimes lack of training the
problem is not enough funding in some
cases and that can actually be the cause
of the problems we're trying to solve so
let's just get really specific about it
let's start with one example many police
departments have become militarized like
armies this is something I talked about
last week and I mentioned last week and
this is super important police training
in the United States is too short and
doesn't deal with how police officers
should actually be trained to be better
stewards of their communities and to
de-escalate situations rather than
escalate situations in many countries
police training is much longer than in
the United States that costs more money
but that extra training should not be
focused on riot control with rubber
bullets it should instead be social work
type training if police were trained
more like social workers and less like
soldiers if police were equipped with
de-escalation tools rather than military
vehicles then we would eliminate many of
the disastrous outcomes that we have
because the first instinct of more
police would be to de-escalate rather
than to say is this a time to pull a gun
or to use a taser taser or to pull out a
nightstick or baton or shield or police
a military a military vehicle but the
reality is that could cost more money it
could cost more money to better trained
police for longer if you double the
amount of time police officers spend in
training from 13 to 26 weeks it's likely
that is going to cost more money not
less and so the sledgehammer of abolish
the police or defund the police fails to
actually achieve what we want I
mentioned militarization when a police
department is militarized they see
themselves more like a military force
than as members of the community and
they solve problems with the tools that
they have again shields military type
vehicles riot control tactics
pepper pepper spray balls and the like
in this case we need to demilitarize the
police now you might do that by
strategically cutting funding for
certain types of training and equipment
in order to achieve the demilitarization
of police beautiful brilliant I'm all
for it but again defund the police or
abolish the police does not actually
leave us better off now in some police
departments the problem is they don't
have enough funding they can't hire
enough officers they can't do community
activism and involvement so when a
police department is underfunded they
resort to the cheap policing of what we
call low-hanging fruit if you are
underfunded and police aren't properly
trained and you don't have the resources
you need to get police involved in the
community
you basically just sent up tons of cops
to poor areas you send the cops you have
to poor areas and as we know those areas
are disproportionately non-white and
they hang out there maybe they do stop
and frisk or similar type tactics and
then they just rack up arrest simply by
saying you know we we don't we send
people to the areas where we believe
there is the most crime and of course
because that's the only area they are in
they find crime there and nowhere else
and it gets up there arrests numbers and
it's the self-fulfilling prophecy that
we know so so well so that's an example
where the police department might
actually be better if they were better
funded not to get shoulder mounted RPGs
and riot gear but to actually have
proper levels of staffing to be involved
in the community to be trained in
de-escalation like social workers let me
give you one more example of this a lot
of police are policing places where they
don't live and in fact sometimes there's
a big divide where you have officers who
live in rural areas outside of a city
policing an urban area and this is not a
good thing for a number of different
reasons when you bring when you have
community members policing their
communities you typically are going to
be much better off because you don't
have Outsiders coming in the people
in the community are going to be better
disposed to the police because it's not
these outsiders from some other place
who just come in and do whatever and
then they leave and they sleep somewhere
else at night and you are going to have
police officers that are more actually
taking a stake in the long-term effects
of their policing rather than just doing
the easy stuff the low-hanging fruit
as I mentioned but in big cities you
might need more funding in order to do
that the reason a lot of police don't
live where they are working is it's too
expensive so this is not me saying give
everybody raises you know umbrella but
the point is in order to achieve
something that would improve a lot of
police departments requires some
percentage of the force to live in the
area that they police it might not be
cheaper you may not be able to do that
simply by defunding so I am is disgusted
and enraged as you are by the horrifying
videos of sick police brutality from the
last ten days of protests my question is
is the funding or abolishing police
really going to solve the problem now a
couple other things that I want to
mention we should have a central
database of bad police actors so that
when there are complaints and when there
are dismissals it's harder for an
officer to hide that when they go and
apply somewhere else and it's harder for
the new to police department to say we
had no idea you have a central database
of bad police actors the unions will
likely oppose this it would be a fight
but it would cost money to maintain such
a database civilian review review boards
for police use of force complaints and
police shootings some cities have done
this that can cost money
mandatory police body cameras that can
cost money now hopefully you'd be able
to reallocate funding away from
militarization and towards cameras etc
but again the catch-all of abolish or
defund does not take into account any of
these details one last thing here as
progressives we should be for government
and state involvement where it makes
sense we want the government involved in
health care for example they're not
enough involved right now we want the
government involved in regulating
industry they do not regulate themselves
effectively when it comes to law
enforcement we actually want government
doing it and
the people because the people sounds
nice when you imagine neighborhood
watches and and how that will work but
you have two problems first the people
in your neighborhood quickly become some
private security firm with the best
lobbyists and can get the most weapons
you know Google cops you get free with
ads but to get better service get Amazon
Prime police and by the way it comes
with being able to watch some TV shows
for free as well we don't want that it
will become the police equivalent of
private prisons or private mercenary
firms that fight wars overseas for us
it's not the progressive option secondly
there is no denying that sometimes you
actually need the scope of state and
government missile defense as a private
endeavor where neighborhoods decide
here's how we're gonna defend ourselves
from missile attacks doesn't really work
well and in the case of policing you
need these state and federal law
enforcement resources to deal with
things that are big like human
trafficking it's too big and too complex
for communities and private industry to
deal with human trafficking and the
global federal state and local elements
that need to be combined so the solution
that is progressive is not defund or
abolish the police its elect the right
people to fix the police ensure that the
police are working for us in the way
that we want and you do that in part by
electing the right people to make those
decisions change the mayor change the
governor change the police chief now one
more thing should other areas have more
funding yes do we need more funding for
teachers in education of course do we
need more funding for public health and
public housing and homelessness and of
course we do that is a separate issue
from defund or abolish the police
absolute last thing on this defund the
police is being hugely boosted by BOTS
online because they know it's divisive
and I hate to tell you that it'll help
trump defunding the police as of two
days ago has 16% support in this country
it's very low there is more support than
ever for reforming the police we
previously discussed did it make sense
in 2018 for Democrats to
on abolish ice even if you support it I
don't believe that that would have been
logical in 2018 I see no evidence that
abolish the police is a good platform
and I believe that it will help Donald
Trump to get reelected if Joe Biden were
to adopt it it would dramatically hurt
his chances of winning in November if
this is still a very prominent issue at
that point tell me where you agree or
disagree